breath of the wild to this day is still
seeing big discoveries
and chances are at some point you were
scrolling through twitter saw some wild
looking clip that made you go
huh that was cool but i have no clue
what happened oh well
and kept scrolling well my name is rin
harasaki creator of the bow spin
technique and with over 2 300 hours on
breath of the wild i'll be going over
these combat clips and breaking them
down for the average player to see
behind the scenes
so you can see just the amount of work
and difficulty that goes into this type
of gameplay
if you like these kind of intense
breakdowns let us know by subscribing
and hitting that like button so you can
break down more clips you want to see
taken apart
first let's watch the whole combat
sequence by itself without any
explanation
this amazing sequence is done by my good
friend yuda from taiwan
this clip has a lot going on under the
hood and shows how fluidly he can
perform all these advanced techniques
back to back
[Music]
all right so let's start at the
beginning we see yuda face off with the
red main lionel
and the lionel starts his charging slash
attack yuta first does a shield jump
this is a basic skill that you normally
wouldn't use in combat you normally use
it for sliding down hills
but this can be used as a quick dodge in
any direction during combat
there's also something done here under
the hood that you couldn't see with your
eyes that i'll explain in a couple
minutes
he then locks onto the lynel and then
starts doing a complex sequence
he first performs a simple bomb drop
this is the fastest way to summon a bomb
in breath of the wild by dropping it
during a jump
pulling one out and setting it down is
much slower in comparison
now comes the hard part the daruk shield
block reset
or dsbr now a regular shield
block reset is a technique in breath of
the wild that allows you to perform
bullet time
anywhere even on flat ground by blocking
an attack or bomb while jumping the hit
knocks you upwards and lets you jump a
second time
what's equivalent to a double jump in
most video games so combining this with
a backflip in this case
lets you get enough height to enter
bullet time anywhere but
the rook's shield block reset is even
harder and adds a second layer to this
try doing the same as above with the
rook's protection on it simply won't
work because the rook's protection
is getting in the way this is where it
takes a lot of skill to jump into the
attack
turn off the rook's protection by
letting go of zl blocking the attack and
backflipping to get the shield block
reset within milliseconds
to get that sought after bullet time try
it yourself it's
not easy alright now that we're airborne
yuda goes for the headshot
knocks down the lionel stunning him but
something strange happens next and link
flips his head downward all of a sudden
and goes into a strange position
this is called a thunderclap rush also
known as tcr
to perform this you have to tap the
attack and arrow shot at the same time
to confuse the game to do bullet time
and flurry rushes back to back also in
breath of the wild you've probably done
it before the standard flurry rush
it's pretty simple you dodge an attack
it goes into slow motion and then you
attack the enemy
what's actually happening is the game is
marking the target so as soon as your
feet touch the ground you will chase
after the target
this mark and chase mechanic is
constantly stored under the hood of the
game's engine every time you block
get hit or get out of a wave of attack
that's dodgeable so remember a couple
minutes ago when i told you to remember
what happened
that shield jump earlier actually marked
the target lionel to be the chase target
now that he has a lock on the lynel this
thunderclap rush uses that mark and will
chase towards the target and flurry rush
them for high damage
without marking the target it would look
like this and would be quite a
disappointment
with this technique the fact that you
can slam them with bow and arrow shots
and flurry rush right after makes this
technique have extremely high damage
capabilities
alright we're 11 seconds in still with
me here's some more
he finishes his rush and jump cancels
sideways and performs a perfect doru
crush
or pdr by dropping a bomb while jumping
detonating it and pairing it mid-air
with the rook's protection on
he's able to trick the game to think
that the bomb was an enemy attack and
force a flurry rush to happen out of
thin air
it's important to note that normally the
rook's ghost appears when you use the
rook's protection
but it does not hear that's because
there was a perfect parry using deruk's
protection
when you release or tap zl there are two
frames in dirk's protection that are
considered perfect
in a game that's 30 frames per second
two frames feels like this
you have to detonate and parry the bomb
perfectly within those two frames
with enough practice you can do it too
okay so with most of the heavy
explanations out of the way now we'll
see some repeats of previously shown
techniques
bomb drop into another daruk shio block
reset or dsbr
but instead of transferring into a
thunderclap rush like last time
we're going to do a mid-air falling
perfect deru crush with a spear
side note normal perfect daru brushes do
not chase the enemy like thunderclap
rushes
so you want to be close while doing this
or use a longer range weapon like a
spear to reach out and attack them
after the spear's flurry rush he then
does a simple technique called item hold
cancelling
link has a very slow recovery animation
after doing spear flurry rushes
so this saves precious time and forces
yourself out of that by holding an item
pretty nifty this is the final stretch
he uses stasis on the lynel and starts
charging to summon urbosa's fury
he then unleashes his attack but with
lightning quick speed switches weapons
so he doesn't have to stick around for
the whole spear charge animation
this is called the urbosa cancel the
best part is our bosa is still being
summoned after this is happening
so you can do whatever you want for half
a second before urbosa even arrives
he then uses that time to quickly switch
the bombs does one last side hop with a
perfect a root brush
with urbosa looking classy in the
background and there we go
this red main lynel was defeated in one
combo without any retaliation but
plenty of style alright time for some
homework
this will be simple homework you can do
at home for people interested in
leveling up their own combat
this one isn't nearly as complicated as
the stuff you just saw and is easy to
access early in the game and is very
useful throughout your whole playthrough
leaf bomb rolling is an easy technique
which launches your remote bombs much
farther than you ever could by just
throwing it
first find any trees and start chopping
them down until you find a korok leaf
once you have make sure to equip your
round bombs
now all you have to do is attack jump
and
drop your bomb make sure that you fully
swing first so that the gust of wind can
catch your bomb
now blow up your bomb super simple but
we can do a little bit more
[Music]
the next step up would be leaf bomb
launching and this gets a little tougher
to do
this lets you launch bombs in any
direction what you want to do is hold r
to be ready to throw while you have the
korok leaf then jump
press cell to drop your bomb and then
release r all before your feet touch
back on the ground
again it's jump press l and then release
r quickly in order if done right you'll
have to launch the bomb with the wind
and you'll have a neat projectile
[Music]
both of these are easy options that are
a neat alternative for hunting puzzling
and combat hopefully you'll have
mastered this technique by the time the
next episode drops
breath of the wild has evolved a ton
with people finding new things almost
daily since its release back in 2017
keeping this game constantly fresh so if
you found a clip recently that you want
me to break down and explain the magic
behind it
subscribe and let me know in the
comments below which one you want
explained
and also these explanations are kept
short and there are many underlying
rules to these techniques so if you want
to know more you can also look up my
combat glossary
thanks again to yuda for the footage and
go follow him because his username is
short for you who's daddy and you who is
damn adorable
and until next time take it easy
you